Guten Tag. Dr. Erbilen ist mein Name. Ich bin zuständige Erstin-Pürsi heute.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Anamnesi-Gespräch durschen.
Ich würde gerne zuerst ein paar Personen betrugende Fragen stellen.
Danach können wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden besprechen.
Alles in Ordnung, Fürsi.
Für mich ist das okay.
Okay, danke. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Hans Meiser.
Meiser. Herr Meiser, können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen büsten?
Gerne. M E I S E R
Okay. Herr Meiser, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt. Ich bin 1953 geboren.
Okay, können Sie bitte Tag und Monaten auch sagen?
Natürlich, der 1. März 1953.
Ich kann leider den Tag nicht verstehen.
1. März? 1. März?
Okay, danke.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Meiser?
Ich bin 1,75 groß.
Und wie viel wegen Sie zur Seite?
85 Kilogramm.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Informationen, Herr Meiser.
Was führt Sie zu uns? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe seit 3 Tagen Beschwerden am rechten Unterschenkel.
Er tut weh und er wird liegt, er ist rot.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Seit 3 Tagen.
Im Verlauf der Zeit haben die Beschwerden schlechter geworden.
Ja, das tut weh und das wird liegt.
Herr Meiser, sind die Streilende Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Die Schmerzen sind die ganze Zeit da.
Ich habe auch schon Schmerzmedikamente genommen.
Welche Medikamente haben Sie eingelassen?
Ich habe zu Hause Ibuprofen gehabt, das habe ich eingelassen.
Können Sie an die Dosierung erinnern?
Nein.
Hat die Ibuprofen Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, das hat ein bisschen die Schmerzen gelindert,
sodass ich Nacht schlafen konnte.
Sie haben diese Tablette abends angenommen, oder?
Ja, jetzt schon die letzten 2 Tage schon.
Okay.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen ganz genau beschreiben,
Herr Meiser, sind Sie dumpfen oder zäh?
Das sind so drückende und brennende Schmerzen.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Auslöser für die Beschwerden aufgefallen?
Nein.
Das war ganz plötzlich, habe ich gemerkt,
dass das Bein rot und dick ist.
Gibt es dort öffene Wunder?
Nein, keine offene Wunder.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Verletzungen in den letzten 2 Wochen?
Ich habe keine Verletzungen bemerkt.
Nein.
Ich habe aber ein Fußpilz schon lange bekannt.
Okay.
Haben Sie diese Fußpilze, deswegen diese Fußpilze,
irgendwelche Medikamente angenommen oder Arzt besuchen?
Ja, das hat mein Arzt mir gesagt, mein Haustart.
Ich habe ein Nagelack bekommen und eine Salbe bekommen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Pilzinfektionen?
Ja, seit schon ungefähr 3 Wochen.
Okay.
Gibt es auch Wärmung an Beinen?
Eine Was?
Wärmung.
Sie haben gesagt, es gibt Röntgen.
Überwärmung.
Es ist ein bisschen warm.
Gibt es etwas, das Schmerzlinder oder verstärkt?
Ich habe ein bisschen gekühlt und das hat schon ein bisschen besser getan.
Okay.
Herr Meister, wie ist es?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein.
Ist das erste Episode für solche Beschwerden?
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerden gehabt?
Ich habe das zum ersten Mal so ausgeträgt.
Okay.
In den letzten 3 Tagen waren Sie beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, der ist leider im Urlaub.
Deswegen konnte ich ihn nicht besuchen.
Okay.
Sie haben nur Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Ja, richtig.
Und auch Ihre Pilzinfektionen, Salbe und Nagelacken.
Genau.
Also, gibt es noch andere Begleiter Beschwerden, Herr Meister?
Ich habe keine weiteren Beschwerden.
Kraftlosung oder Krüppen an den Beinen?
Krüppen habe ich immer.
Beide Beine oder nur Rechte?
Beide Beine.
Und auch Ihre Bekleidung?
Ja, das ist schon seit Jahren.
Also, gibt es bestimmte Gründe,
dass Ihr Arzt Ihnen erklärt habe für Krüppen?
Ja, also das habe ich schon seit Jahren.
Er sagt, das ist wegen dem Zucker.
Zucker, okay.
Ja, so, die Beschwerden nur an rechten Beinen, ja?
Richtig, ja, recht unterstecken.
Okay, die Pilzinfektion auch nur rechte Fuß?
Beide Füße.
Beide.
Ja, so, gibt es, ja, haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Schutteilfrost?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Übelkeit oder Erbrechen, haben Sie auch?
Nein.
Okay.
Meister, leiden Sie unter Atemnot oder Herzstorpern?
Nein.
Okay, so.
Was ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, ganz konzentriert.
Ich könnte ein bisschen abnehmen, aber ich habe es irgendwie nicht.
Okay, so.
Es ist ein guter Appetit.
Sehr gut.
Hat Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit merklich verändert?
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Also ich kann mein Gewicht jetzt so halten.
Ich habe früher mehr gewogen.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf, Herr Meister?
Ja, in den letzten drei Tagen nicht so gut, weil ich schon Schmerzen habe,
aber mit dem Profen geht das gut.
Okay.
So, gibt es Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Ich meine Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay, so Wasser lassen auf gut, ja?
Ja, nicht so gut.
Ich muss nachts oft aufstehen, auf die Toilette gehen.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette in der Nacht?
Ja, so zweimal muss ich schon aufstehen, nachts.
Okay.
Können Sie im Bett flachlegen oder brauchen Sie mehrere Kissen?
Nein, ich kann flachlegen.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Und Herr Meister, ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen über Ihre Vorerkrankungen geschickt.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Zuckerkrankheit.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Seit wann?
Okay.
Typ 1 oder Alterszuckerkrankheit.
Bist du die Zuckerkrankheit?
Also ich muss keinen Solien nehmen.
Ich nehme nur Medikamente ein, Tabletten.
Werche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme Metformin ein.
Ich nehme Metformin.
Wie viele Mal pro Tag?
Zwei Mal am Tag.
Zwei Mal.
Okay.
Können Sie an die Dosierung erinnern, Herr Meister?
1000.
1000 Medikamente.
Okay.
Gibt es noch andere Vorerkrankungen außer Diabetes, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, Blutdruck.
Ich habe Blutdruck noch.
Dann nehme ich auch für Medikamente ein.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Das ist schon lange.
Seitdem ich 40 bin, habe ich schon Blutdruck.
14.
Seitdem ich 40 Jahre alt bin, habe ich schon...
40, okay.
Und welche Medikamente nehmen Sie dagegen?
Dann nehme ich ganz viele ein.
Ich habe über drei Tabletten, glaube ich, eine aufgeschrieben.
Können Sie sich an den Namen Medikamente erinnern?
Ja, das ist einmal Candesatan heißt das.
Und dann habe ich eines Moxonidin.
Moxonidin.
Moxonidin, ja.
Wie viele Mal nehmen Sie ein?
Einmal morgens.
Und das andere ist Amlodipin.
Das ist auch einmal, oder?
Das ist auch zweimal.
Als ich nehme Candesatan und Amlodipin,
beides zweimal ein.
Können Sie an die Dosierung von diesen Medikamenten erinnern?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Kein Problem.
Wir können von Ihrem Hausarzt erfahren.
Wer ist aber Moal auch?
Okay, später, kein Problem.
Sie haben Zuckerkrankheit und Bluthochdruck.
Gibt es Probleme bei der Blutfetwerte?
Ja, stimmt.
Dann nehme ich auch noch etwas ein.
Abends einen Medikament. Habt den Namen vergessen.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Hochblutfetwerte?
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Schon lange.
Okay.
Das ist alles, oder?
Wie meinen Sie das alles?
Alles für Erkrankungen.
Ich habe noch erhöhte Heransäure.
Ich habe noch etwas für die Heransäure.
Nehmen Sie etwas dagegen?
Ja, morgen.
Hallo, Pyrinol heißt es.
Sie nehmen viele Medikamente ein.
Ich bin ja schon alt, ich bin ja nicht mehr jung.
Nicht so alt, Herr Meiser, aber ja.
Also, würden Sie schon einmal operieren, Herr Meiser?
Ja, ich habe schon mal meine Geilenblase rausnehmen lassen.
Elenden Sie sich die Datum?
Da war ich 50 Jahre alt, also 20 Jahre ungefähr.
Okay.
War die Operation komplikationlos?
Ja, das war okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt wegen der Blutzucker oder Bluthochdruck?
Das ist aber lange her, wo ich wegen dem Blutzucker behandelt habe.
Da war er ziemlich hoch, aber das waren ein paar Tage.
Und ich habe eine neue Hüfte.
Die Hüfte ist neu bei mir.
Ich habe eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Wann war die Hüfte-Operation?
Die Hüfte-Operation war vor fünf Jahren.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Okay.
Sind Sie allergisch auf bestimmten Stoff oder Medikamente?
Ja, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, auch nicht bekannt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Meiser, rappen Sie?
Nein.
Okay, sehr schön.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten, zwei oder dreimal im Jahr.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Sport regelmäßig?
Ich fahre Fahrrad.
Jedem Tag oder?
Geht so.
Wenn es wetterschön ist, dann versuche ich aufzufahren.
Herr Meiser, haben Sie früher gerafft oder niemals?
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwirkt, meine Frau ist verstorben.
Es tut mir leid.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind erwachsen in München.
Gut.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Sie sind zurzeit Rentner, aber früher, was haben Sie als Beruflüft gemacht?
Ich war in der Fabrik als Schlosser tätig.
Schlosser tätig.
Schlosser, ja.
Wie ist Ihr im Status, Herr Meiser?
Mein Haushalt meinte, das wäre okay.
Gegen Corona sind Sie auch geimpft?
Ja, fünfmal.
Okay.
War es in den letzten drei Monaten im Ausland?
Nein.
Danke.
Ja, gibt es wichtige Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Also, meine Eltern sind ja gestorben.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wissen Sie, woran Ihr Eltern gestorben?
Mein Vater ist im Krieg verstorben.
Und meine Mutter hatte Alzheimer-Demenz.
Ja, Sie sind ein Selkens, ja?
Ja.
Herr Meiser, ich möchte eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen,
wenn Sie mich etwas falsch verstehen oder vergessen.
Sie haben seit drei Tagen in den Rechten unter Schmerzen und Rötung bemerkt.
Die Schmerzen sind drückende und brennende.
Sie haben auch über Wärmung am Rechten unter Schenker.
Sie bemerkt, ja, keine Auslöser gibt es.
Und Kühlung hilft ihr Schmerzen.
Sie haben auch seit drei Wochen Pilzinfektionen bei den Püsse.
Und keine Fieber.
Ja, Sie haben auch Kreepen wegen der Zuckerkrankheit.
Und Sie gehen zweimal auf die Toilette.
Ja, so gibt es noch etwas, was Sie möchten, Sie hinzufügen?
Nein, wissen Sie schon, was ich habe?
Herr Meiser, ich denke, Sie haben unter Schenker Infektionen wegen der Pilzinfektionen.
Diese Infektion steigt ein bisschen auf den rechten Bein.
Deswegen müssen wir zuerst körperlich untersuchen und nehme ich Blut ab.
Dann werde ich auf eine Röntgen-Grafie von der rechten Unterschenkel veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, können wir noch einmal mit Ihnen über die Diagnose und Therapiemöglichkeiten besprechen.
Glauben Sie, dass ich hier im Krankenhaus bleiben muss?
Wenn ich wieder nach Hause bin, weil ich eine Katze zu Hause habe?
Ich verstehe, je nach Ergebnisse werde ich diese Entscheidung treffen.
Aber wenn Sie hier bei uns bleiben sollten, können wir auch für Ihre Katze helfen.
Ja, wie wollen Sie das dann machen mit der Katze?
Ja, das ist falsch.
Kommt man jemand von Ihnen zu mir nach Hause?
Nein, nein, nein. Sie können vielleicht nicht, ich habe fast gesagt, Sie können vielleicht eine bekannte Bescheid geben.
Ja, ich habe aber leider keine, das ist blöd.
Nein, egal, müssen wir mal schauen. Machen Sie erst mal die Untersuchung und dann gucken wir mal.
Okay, okay. Danke. Sie sollten jetzt unter den Untersuchung-Raum gehen, dann komme ich gleich.
Okay, dann bis gleich.
Dankeschön.
Ein Kollege, der eine Frau aus dem Haus von einem Kollegen, hat eine Frage.
Insekten ist der Markt, unter Beinen?
Bitte?
Insekten ist, haben wir den Markt, unter Beinen?
Insekten, insekten, insekten, insekten bis?
Ja.
Nein, ich habe keinen Insektenstich oder Insekteneintrittsforte gesehen.
Gut, wo gehen die Haute?
An meinem Unterschenkel, und das geht bis jetzt, das zieht hoch und auch am Vorfuß.
Vorfuß.
Und am Unterschenkel.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Ja, sehr stark.
Was bedeutet sehr stark, wie schön?
Und triggbare Schmerzen oder?
Also das beeinträchtigt mich sehr, ich kann dann nicht schlafen,
deswegen habe ich über Profingen genommen.
Was meinen Sie, sehr stark schmerzen, unerträglich?
8 bis 9, 7.
Ach so, meinen Sie das?
Meinen Sie von einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Ja.
Ah, ok.
Also 6, 7 schon.
Haben Sie denn bemerkt, in der leichte Schwillung?
Wir haben genau das.
Eine gute Frage? Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind verliebt, Herr Kollege.
Als erstes geht es um die eigene Anfange.
Ich bin auf die Anfange, Herr Kollege.
Anfange, wir an.
Esin Abla.
Ok, ich versuche jetzt.
Guten Morgen Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient gerade gesehen.
Ich möchte ihn gerne vorstellen.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Gerne, bitte schön.
Danke.
Es geht um Hans Meiser.
Er ist 70 Jahre alt und 1,75 Meter groß.
85 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Hans Meiser hat sich heute Morgen bei uns wegen seit 3 Tagen plötzlich aufgetretene,
durkende, bremende, dauerhafte und progrä diente starke Schmerzen in Rehten und Erschenkel vorgestellt.
Außerdem berichtet der Patient, dass die Schmerzen im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden sind.
Er hat auch Rötung, Überwärmung an den betroffenen Ort bemerkt.
Es gibt keine Auslöser, ist bei der Patientin aufgefallen.
Die Frage nach Verletzungen wurde verneint.
Als begünstiger Faktor seit 3 Wochen Pilzinfektionen an den beiden Füssen.
Er hat deswegen eine Zelle angewandt.
Die Schmerzen sind beim krüllen Besser geworden.
Als begleitende Symptome klagte er über Krippen an den beiden Beinen.
Ist das neu oder bekannt?
Es ist nicht neu, sondern seit Jahren haben er Krippen wegen Diabetes mei Lütus.
Hat er noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, er habe.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei unauffällig bis auf Schmerzbedingte seit 3 Tagen Schlafstörungen und Nükturi 2 Mal in der Nacht.
Er hat seit 20 Jahren Diabetes mei Lütus, Arterielehypertone seit 30 Jahren, Hyperlipideme und Hyperlipideme.
Er hat keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bei ihm bekannt.
Es wurde eine Polystectomie mit 50 Lebensaltern durchgeführt.
Er hat eine Attake stationär behandelt.
Er hat eine Medikamente mit Formen 1.000 pro Tag eingegangen.
3 Mal 1.000 oder 2 Mal?
Ich habe 3 Mal verstanden, aber bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich noch mal fragen.
Ich habe 2 Mal mit dem Moxonidin eingegangen, der Amlodipin 2 Mal pro Tag.
Er hat auch eine Alopyrinol-Tablette eingegangen.
Er hat noch andere Medikamente eingegangen, Hyperlipideme, aber der Patient hat sich an den Namen leider nicht erinnern.
Er ist nicht rauf, er trinkt sehr selten Alkohol.
Er hat Sport, Farad, Er ist verwidert und hat 2 gesunde Erwachsene.
Er ist zurzeit Rentner, aber früher war er schlosset tätig in einem Firma.
Sein Impfstatus sei vollständig, die Reise einer Mese sei unerfällig.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich Vater, ist während Krieg verstorben.
Mutter ist aufstorben, aber sie hat Alzheimer-Demons.
Er ist ein Zeltkind.
Alle Anamnestischen Angaben dort sind auf einer Ersüperlkind.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen TVT und PAFK-Fieleinbetracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zuerst den Patienten förbärlich untersuchen.
Danach werde ich Blut ab.
Beim Labor bestimme ich BSG, CAP, Blutbild und auch HBAA1C.
Ich werde auch eine Kultur nehmen.
Um eine Fraktur zu schließen, kann Torax Recht und Torax Recht unterschenken.
Es gibt keine Anamnestischen Angaben.
Warum wollen Sie den Unterschied röntgen?
Ich werde auch meine Differenzialdiagnose auszuschließen.
Um eine TVT auszuschließen.
Im Blut können Sie noch etwas abnehmen.
Ich muss auch D-Demons bestimmen.
Wie würden Sie das behandeln?
Je nach Ergebnisse werde ich Penicillin zuerst verabreichen.
Wenn die Pilzeinfektionen sehr stark antifungal sind, dann können wir die Tablette schreiben.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten auf und lassen sie nach Hause gehen.
Es gab keine Fieber, die nicht so schlecht stand.
Ich werde den Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Aber wegen der Diabetes, die aktuelle Zustand, ich werde ihm auch Diabetische-Fuss-Pflege empfehlen.
Wovon machen Sie das?
Es hängt von der Untersuchung und auch der Zustand des Patienten.
Wenn es eine Hypergulikeme oder eine Metabolische-Impalance gibt, dann können wir die Patienten aufnehmen.
Sie würden die mit Penicillin behandeln?
Was würden Sie noch machen, um das Bein mitzubehandeln?
Es gibt auch Schmerzmitglieds.
Die Immobilisation ist nicht so stark, aber die Bein muss sich erholen.